it's the same thing it's the same
fascist tactic to say oh no no that's
all [ __ ] don't trust them trust me
and you know and we talked with jim
yesterday about how this whole thing
happened right you got people that are
isolated
online during the pandemic like all of
these factors were perfect in this in
this storm of crazy conspiracy [ __ ]
to manipulate people to make them think
something that they wouldn't otherwise
think if if the conditions were
different
and so it's that same thing of trump and
republicans being like that's fake news
that's fake news can't trust them and by
default it's you can trust me so now
everything i say is the absolute truth
and if anyone says otherwise then they
are the enemy of the state
speaking of fascist
have you seen the pennsylvania mussolini
this [ __ ] guy holy [ __ ] what listen
to what this is this is a masteriano yo
you mean the insurrectionist yeah he is
a [ __ ] traitor but listen
listen to how he describes women's
freedom here
he really it seems like he doesn't like
the idea of women's freedom listen i
don't give a way for exceptions either
kathy barnett is going to be our next
next u.s senator she is a product of
rape okay thanks
okay this isn't very long but there's a
lot of [ __ ] packed in these few seconds
here now again this is the
insurrectionist
this is the incorrectness which if if we
go by the judge's decision on coy
griffin the cowboys for trump guy the
commissioner out in new mexico if you go
by that if even if this [ __ ]
wins he'll probably be 14th and he'll be
removed from office because he's an
insurrectionist
but here's the thing
it really gets me that this guy shaves
his head and he looks like mussolini
right yeah i mean come on is this a joke
this is a [ __ ] joke i don't know he
makes me think like he's trying to look
like like bruce willis or something oh
you think
not really pulling it off you think i'm
supposed to play a good mussolini i'm
trying to think like oh he looks he
looks like my thumb actually he does
kind of look like a [ __ ] thumb didn't
he it's thumb with a tie on but here he
is saying i don't like women to have any
freedom whatsoever even if
their life is in danger because of rape
or incest or just because the pregnancy
goes south and their life is in danger
[ __ ] them they don't get to have freedom
and then he says the senator because i'm
i'm thinking he's referring to the
republican uh nominee who's gonna get
crushed i don't know who is he talking
about here yeah what is what does he say
who is he saying well watch watch i
don't give a way for exceptions either
kathy barnett is going to be our next
next u.s senator she is a product of
rape okay
kathy barnett is she the one who lost dr
oz is this got up this videos gets to be
old i guess kathy barnett i don't see
congressional district pennsylvania for
she's representative
she was running for the u.s senate so
she
so this this is this is but also what
the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] like no idea
look i don't know whether she has come
out publicly and talked about this but
even so
that is not really something that's your
business to like throw that [ __ ] out
there like
if someone's gonna air that out for the
public you know and they do it under
their own terms for whatever the
narrative they're trying to create
that's fine you know they can do what
they want but i feel like it's very much
an overreach
of someone's privacy and personal story
and trauma of you know of going through
that that for him just like oh yeah
she's a product of rape like you think
this guy you think this guy cares about
other people's trauma oh no not at all
this guy's like [ __ ] women [ __ ] their
freedom [ __ ] their life i don't give a
[ __ ] no exception no exception if you're
if you're a 12 year old that was raped
by a family member and you get pregnant
you got to carry that [ __ ] to
term right even if it kills you because
there's no exception you think well they
don't
[ __ ] do you think he has any empathy for
anyone else's story come on oh no not at
all no no i i don't i don't think they
do i mean well you know keep in mind
this is magga right this is maggot that
is it's [ __ ] oh my god they
within eight seconds it describes them
you